yorkshire terrier harry hallo leute ich
es wieder auch mal waren bekommen zu
einer neuen folge wie schmeckt heute ist
eine ganz besondere folge und nicht nur
wir hätten mit geburtstagskaffee vater
macht sondern weil ich diese woche jeden
tag ein video hochladen bis sonntag denn
ich habe am 9.9 also am samstag
geburtstag und das soll die
geburtstagswoche auf mal wanne werden
stirn bot
leute ich tu's ich schwöre ich mag es
mit ein bisschen rutschig hier also
lasst uns diese woche ganz viel spaß
zusammen haben und jetzt geht's los
was ich jetzt im internet herausfinden
konnte war dass helmut den google selbst
gemacht hat dass der aus schokolade ist
und nur buttercreme obendrauf und die
harry schriftlich sollten wir doch im
krieg ganz kleiner und wichtige
information am rand heute ist so sondern
wolke sonne wolken das heißt das licht
mit sich die ganze zeit verändert habe
halt keine küche kein also ich habe kein
studio in dem ich drin deswegen haben
wir auch im youtube mehr authentisch
fangen wir an mit dem teig hat den
kunden selbst gemacht das heißt es
müsste eigentlich ein britisches rezept
sein ich weiß nicht auf eine hecke mit
dem wald lebt bzw da am rand der sich
ein rezept erhält dass er überhaupt
kochen kann
ganz ehrlich wenn ich den nicht so gut
hinkriege wie hagrid dann zweifle ich
habe im internet ein rezept gefunden für
ein europaweites chocolate zwang bacon
until you make it sollte die stadt
verkaufen auf windows drauf killed and
then you made weil dieses format echt
meine miete
wir brauchen ja ja und jetzt schnäppchen
moment daran brauchen die noch zucker
und butter von einer kuh mutter
jetzt wird es spannend safe racing
flower es gibt in britannien den usa
geht das schon backpulver und natron
drin hat wie in deutschland
handarbeit deswegen bauen wir mehl
backpulver natron und beschlusses hat
selbst und ganz ganz wichtig kakaopulver
der gugl bensdorf holländischer
tradition getreuen seit 1840 aus wien
cacau den herrgott kaufen würde oder er
würde nicht so fancy marken kaufen die
drk oder so dann wird auch die klassiker
zurückgreift hätte dafür auch nicht
zaubern deswegen können wir den ganz in
ruhe wie normale menschen machen ja ich
muss aber sagen das rezept ist ein
kleines abenteuer weil ich drei eier
wiegen soll und aufgrund von dessen
gewicht dann die anderen zutaten
anpassen soll es keinen mix vorgegeben
auf die eier kommt es an beschuldigung
leute müssen uns meine eier wegen gehen
oh mein gott was hier haben wir 180
gramm eier
wisst ihr was neuer plan heck und hat
sich bestimmt auch diese krassen rezepte
gehalten und dieses rezept ist wirklich
seltsam ich weiß jetzt ungefähr was rein
soll und wie gehen einfach mal in heavy
rain in seinen körper legen uns wie viel
er von was genommen haben könnt ich weiß
auf jeden fall das ist eine gute idee es
für einen flüssigen teig das eiweiß vom
eigelb zu trennen und schaum zu
schreiben und ich finde wir leben 4
denn der wollen die haters gott zu viel
locken videos oder eigentlich diese
videos nicht nur manchmal wenn sie mir
vorgeschlagen dann schauen sie doch auch
vier trainings unser eiweiß und eigelb
wo ich werde immer besser das
funktioniert bestimmt noch mal so machen
es die chefköche auch ganz dumme idee so
er zu trennen ich glaube hettstadt
einfach in der küche hat sich seine
gelben angeschaut und gesagt hier in
garding liebloser den hit markt bestimmt
süße sachen bestimmt eine kleine
naschkatzen der hecken und er dachte
sich auch harry hat solange
wahrscheinlich keine süßigkeiten
bekommen oder wusste er dass es ihm so
schlecht dort geht bei mir gerade echt
nicht so
sicher weil ich nicht dies wird die weiß
so alle fun fact und so richtig ein
bisschen aufgedreht geburtstagskindes
hier geht es auf meine damen und herren
wenn ihr zucker mit beigemischt werde
jetzt in dieser schüssel mehl backpulver
natron noch mal extra anrühren und dann
ist zu den eiern dazu geben würde wäre
es mit wehrheim backpulver röhrig die
trockenen zutaten wir sind ein bisschen
verrückt weil hätte glaube ich auch
verrückt ist und machen das kakaopulver
in die eier mischung sein
wir machen mal ein bisschen aus wie
tiramisu
ich glaube wir sollten die butter
dazugeben jetzt denken uns mal mit zahl
aus ich glaube ich nehme 200 gramm
butter ein mixer hast mir dieses foto
zeigt kann auf jeden fall noch einen
schuss vanille milch vertragen so jetzt
gehen wir nach und nach ein bisschen
mehl in unsere schokoladen mischen und
rühren sie rein
okay leute weil es wie ich das
hinbekommen habe aber dieser teig ist
bis jetzt einfach perfekt also wenn das
was wird dann habe ich einfach ein
rezept gefunden
noch habe ich die kugel aber nicht
probiert und das machen wir weiter mit
dem eiweiss einmal bitte steif schlagen
irgendwann mal gelesen das mit einer
prise salz besser wäre eine prise seite
in der ai weiweis ist komplett steif und
kommt jetzt natürlich zu unserer
schokoladen mission hallo
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie sahne das
müssen jetzt und erheben
das sieht einfach aus wieso muss ich
schon mal gucken muss jetzt in so eine
kuchenform ich weiß natürlich nicht
welche größe das ist ich glaube es ist
26 könnt jetzt auch noch messen aber ich
hab kein leben ja auf jeden fall möchte
ich jetzt trick 17 machen und da unten
so backpapier tun damit man ihnen später
wieder gut raus trägt für diesen trick
liegt das papier auf die platte
das andere wegen ein paar jetzt noch
schönen land abschneiden und fertig ist
der rock für eure kuchenform
nichtsdestotrotz mache ich noch an den
rand ein bisschen butter ganz dumme idee
es mit messer zu machen und jetzt können
wir unseren älterer flogen teig da
rhein-main
der kommt jetzt für gute 40 bis 50
minuten brauchen dann 80 grad in den
backofen und dann schauen wir mal ob da
was geworden ist nach 50 minuten später
das ist unser schlugen erst aufgeplatzt
und noch ultra heißt deswegen sollten
wir ihn jetzt erstmal abkühlen lassen
und in der zeit machen wir die leckere
buttercreme jetzt stellt sich die frage
was für eine buttercreme so der hang
mitmachen und die antwort ist ganz
einfach eine fertigmischung buttercreme
aus holland denn mit seinem motorrad ist
einmal ganz schnell unterwegs und von
england nach holland kommt er eben mal
rüber fliegen und ich weiß das heißt
eigentlich niederlande und ich hoffe ich
meinen wert bestimmt genug im wald zu
tun kann jetzt noch hier buttercreme
groß allerdings machen 250 gramm pulver
und mit dem koks geht jetzt auf die
nächste geburtstagsparty und macht mal
eine richtige party gut ist richtig voll
gut richtig so eine buttercreme sollte
auch buttercreme werden 250 milliliter
wasser und jetzt führen wir das da rein
das müssen wir jetzt zusammen kennt ihr
diese eine folge
das muss jetzt eine stunde lang ruhen
also bis dann wird es draußen langsam
dunkel das sollte uns aber nicht
aufhalten denn ich dir heute am
geburtstag und ich will diese torte
mitnehmen und deswegen machen die
schnell weitere sieht jetzt aus wie so
eine silikonform machen dass es mir
jetzt tun diebe packung dann ist oder im
kopf einschalten okay wir sollen jetzt
butter schaumig schlagen
neben mir und eine rührschüssel damit
300 gramm von diesem zeug benutzt und
wissen mit 350 gramm butter ich glaube
ich habe nicht mehr so viel butter ich
heute mein gott
deswegen machen gucken auch trägt weil
da so viel bitter drin ist na dann lass
uns mal die butter schaumig schlagen und
bildungspolitische schaue mich ist dann
nehmen wir uns mal was von dieser butter
kleben sie ziemlich das vieh zu helfer
das ist wie unsere buttercreme muss er
jetzt auch noch rosa werden und fühlen
wenn wir hier in pinkl einzigen koller
muss auf jeden fall ein bisschen dollar
knapp denken weil wir ja noch die
schrift machen müssen ich werde diesmal
ganz wenig nehmen weil sie verpackt
machen ich habe es schon einmal so
schlecht ja ist die farbe die wir
brauchen kinder es ist ein bisschen über
lichte deswegen liegt man das jetzt
gehören wir uns um die schrift und dafür
brauchen wir grün jetzt welche gespannt
ob es auch grünen das grün wird ich
könnte es jetzt verpacken aber ich
möchte so eine ganz kleine messerspitze
blauen noch dazu machen weil es ist eher
das hat so einen bläulichen stich meiner
deckung gegeben hat war es ja dunkel
deswegen kann es sein dass in echt auch
ein bisschen kritischer ist passt
eigentlich schon oder ist schon gute
farben mit einer sache habe der absolut
nicht gerechnet und zwar habe ich einen
karton gekauft indem man den kunden
reinpacken kann
das ist so eine richtige box zum gucken
transportieren
ich habe jetzt von dem kuchen die obere
schicht weggenommen weil er halt so ein
bisschen schief geworden ist jetzt schön
gerade und jetzt kommt die rosa gremium
drauf und ich war ja nicht ich bin ich
nicht ein super fans gerät gekauft hatte
um die cremes verstreichen
ähnlich aus wie bei sun ist orten wählt
er funktioniert gar nicht mal so
schlecht zu viele cellisten welt videos
gesehen ich schon vor das gefühl dafür
wie man das macht so leute guckt euch
das an so könnte das besser sehen voll
gut ich bin ich bin echt stolz auf mich
ich muss sagen sonst ein bisschen
gedauert alles so zu verteilen und so
aber wenn man sich mühe gibt dann wird
das auch was jetzt kommt allerdings der
schwierigste teil und zwar die schrift
ich habe mich ja nicht lumpen lassen und
haben spritzbeutel zeit gekauft ich habe
das nämlich schon mal alles trocken welt
gesehen da macht sie das nicht hin so
ein glas rein und jetzt kann man dass da
einfach einführen
so kommt man hier können wir das
schaffen yo wir schaffen das ich bin so
nervös
gar nicht mal so schlecht
gotthard hat weil gott ich bin stolz
drauf weiß es nicht perfekt geworden
die schrift auch nicht eins zu eins
kopieren können aber das kann man schon
mal auf der geburtstagsparty mitbringen
das ist schon cool diese kugel halterung
ist nicht ganz so groß wie die von
hellgate aber leute freude
ich bin so stolz drauf um in kürze jetzt
stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt
harry potters geburtstagskuchen von
hellgate das kann ich aber jetzt nicht
beantworten denn ich nehme den gucken
damit auch die party und ich will nicht
dass dann stück von fehlt ich werde
versuchen die kamera mitzunehmen und zu
film ansonsten sagt euch morgen wieder
geschmeckt hat aber ich werde wohl
empfehlen wie ich den probiert aber ganz
ehrlich scheiß doch darauf wieder
schmeckt er sieht einfach nur geil aus
so deckel drauf und auf geht's zur party
würde ich sagen
[Musik]
endlich kam diese drei bücher hier
wertvolle machen bauen
[Musik]